quand on avait russe économies de ses
internationaux plus de 2 millions de
questions ont été envoyés pour cette
ligne directe avec vladimir poutine
cette année l'exercice a duré seulement
3 heures 42 minutes
le chef d'état russe a répondu à 69
question la plupart des requêtes
concernaient la gestion de la crise
sanitaire en russie vladimir poutine a
notamment répondu à la question
concernant un éventuel confinement les
décisions des administrations des dix
régions
justement cette fonction d'éviter le
confinement plus que le confinement
c'est ce sont les gens qui restent sans
salaire ce sont les banqueroutes des pme
et la baisse des revenus des gens alors
pour l'éviter dans certaines régions on
prévoit la vaccination obligatoire pour
éviter la diffusion de l'épisode et
l'épidémie il n'y a qu'une seule voie
la vaccination nous avons cette
possibilité parce que nous avons quatre
vaccins et qui sont hautement
technologiques très sécurisée et
efficace et j'espère que certaines
certaine retenue de nos gens vont
disparaître la politique extérieure
était également évoqué les spectateurs
rues sont interrogés vladimir poutine
sur les relations russo ukrainiennes et
une rencontre avec le président
ukrainien vladimir ilic écouter les gens
sont confinés dans leurs propres amendes
mais je ne crois pas que le peuple
ukrainien c'est un peuple aussi la
russie non pas du tout nous faisons un
ensemble tandis que les autorités
ukrainiennes actuelle ce
on occupe une position aussi l'envers la
russie ça c'est évident à quoi bon nous
rencontrer avec monsieur alinsky 6 et
l'ukraine sous l'autorité de céline ce
qu'ils sont contrôlés de l'extérieur est
les aspects clés de la vie en ukraine
sont décidées à washington à berlin à
paris mais bien sûr je ne renonce pas à
ces rencontres là mais je veux
comprendre de quoi on va parler
impossible d'imaginer une ligne directe
ce sont les questions sur les relations
russo américaines après les sommets
poutine baden
à genève les spectateurs russes demander
à quoi ça sert de rencontrer le
président américain
écoutez nos partenaires américains
comprennent d'un côté c'est cette
évolution c'est pourquoi il ya la
rencontre à genève mais de l'autre côté
coûte que coûte il persiste à dominer
toujours le monde et il ya de ce fait
toutes sortes de menaces cette prise de
conscience du monde qui évolue et en ce
monde qui évolue il y aura la nouvelle
prise conscience de ses propres
priorités de ses propres intérêts t cela
va amener vers la situation où là le
monde soit plus raisonnable plus
équilibrée et nos échanges avec les
états unis seront normalisées après
avoir remercié les téléspectateurs et
les différents intervenants vladimir
poutine a conclu cette ligne directe par
une promesse de faire tout son possible
pour chaque demande
chaque roquette chaque appel soit
l'objet de son attention